hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
for one of my form you just hurts who is
asking about email marketing and list
building and read the specific question
so we wrote insane really could use some
with sound advice I'm building my email
list it's limited now but growing slowly
I've added an email opt-in for my
website but wanted to dip my toes into
the water with a bulk email program is a
program called send blaster and I want
to buy a smallish targeted email list
can anyone throw some light on the
software choice is that a good what do I
need to look for when buying email list
and thank you sorry how to ensure I'm
not forgetting spamming loss thank you
in advance you views so thanks for the
question hurts a couple things for you I
guess here I've never heard of this this
program before send blaster I use Aweber
found it really helpful and for me in
terms of building the opt-in and also
sending emails out on a regular basis
and the emails have become almost part
of the backbone of what I do with my
business it's great to be able to
connect with with my readers on an
ongoing basis so I really preach the
value of having a list and building it
up and sending out regular updates if
it's a weber or any other software in
terms of buying the list i'd be really
careful about this terms of breaking the
spamming laws you want to make sure that
people are opting into your list so
definitely having something on your
website if you have some kind of free
download or give away more likely to get
people to convert and want to sign up
for your list in terms of mindless i
would probably not do it what i might
want to do if you're looking at trying
to increase the number of people on your
list is do some kind of joint venture so
you look at other people who have a list
and you offer them either some money or
some kind of partnership where they
promote you to their list so it's it's
way better to do it where you're getting
recommendation from their list so i
don't really do it on my list but for
example if your partner with somebody
like me i could say no hurts has a great
service go check it out or he's got this
free resource that he's offered on his
website go check it out and that'll go
to my sixty thousand plus list of
entrepreneurs so that would be a much
better way to convert people because
people my list are used to hearing from
me they like my recommendations most of
the time at least i hope and that
personal endorsement goes a long way to
be able to convert people it's way
better than just you know buying my list
which i never sell but as an example if
you were to buy my list and just spam
them or send them some kind of offer
because it's not coming from me they
don't know who you are they're getting
bombarded with emails every day they're
not probably going to convert to become
your news o subscriber or buy your
product or service so two paths first
continue building on your own try to
build some kind of opt-in where you're
getting some kind of free bonus if they
sign up for your newsletter to increase
your conversions and then be partner
with people who already have lists and
try to come up with some kind of joint
venture where you're both by the Finney
family and they're recommending you to
their list and you're going to get a lot
more conversions than just finding this
we're going to vote breaking a lot
spending money on acquiring that list
and it's a lot more fun you know when
you're doing something with a lot of
added value and you're being recommended
we're giving away free bonuses you're
adding value to your potential clients
and it's way more fun than just spamming
people and getting the whole bunch of
people saying take me off your list so
hope that helps hurts again if you're
going to use Aweber it's great or
another similar kind of email software
if you guys like this video please give
it a thumbs up below it's what makes me
want to do more these videos you guys
and if you have a question about email
marketing or what I do or another
question about your business feel free
to leave in the comments below I always
read those and try to answer as many as
I can so thank you and we'll see you on
the next
you